marie-jeanne janville bonjour géoméga
riches pourquoi vous présentez vous aux
élections législatives et alors que vous
étiez il n'ya pas longtemps avec le
rassemblement national et que là pour
ces législatives 2022 vous êtes sous la
bannière du mouvement reconquête un
parti politique menée par eric zemmour
oui tout d'abord je dis bonjour aussi à
tous ceux que tous les auditeurs et que
nous écoute cet instant est bon je vais
pas recommencer à raconter mon histoire
politique c'est vrai que j'étais avec
marine j'ai eu des problèmes avec une
martiniquaise de madame fatna en même
temps je venais de perdre mon fils donc
tout ça tout ça apm a fait que je n'ai
pas pu faire face et puis je me suis
retiré de 2 to et là je reviens avec
bois je reviens cros conquête parce que
c'est vrai que madame marine le pen
c'est un petit peu à moulis sous ces
deux projets et monsieur zemmour qui la
société civile qui arrive qui est tout
neuf et qui parle vrai comme moi même et
a repris ce jeudi le flambeau et le
projet de monsieur zemmour franc de
notre sens pour tous les jeunes qui ont
quitté bien ceux qui sont en reconquête
tranquillité
et surtout depuis avec marion au fn on
était déjà la mouvance mario pour
l'union des droites d'accord marion
maréchal un gabarit alors quels sont les
deux ou trois projets prioritaires pour
la martinique que vous comptez défendre
si vous êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale
bien donc étant dans un parti nous
sommes sans 555 investi dans le toit mer
il et la france hexagonale nous
souhaitons être au gouvernement bien sûr
et monsieur zemmour qui est tout frais
qui arrive comme j'ai dit barrineuf
gabarit bien nous allons lui soumettre
les dossiers donc tout sera sous la
table et il ya des lois amendées ad loi
révisée et à des lois
et peut-être aussi qu'il faudrait
complètement à bouger et je prends le
cas par exemple sur la safer la loi qui
régit la safer je crois que j'en ai
parlé à mes amis autour de moi surtout à
monsieur j vinalies tous qu'ils me
disent oui mais tout laisse à fait gouda
magouilles de tris à faire le jeu de
monsieur zemmour là si m et je crois
qu'il faut avoir un petit peu cette loi
parce que il ya beaucoup de jeunes
agriculteurs qui ont du mal à trouver de
quoi pour travailler et on voit que
d'autres quoi qui viennent d'ailleurs
pour nomades nommer quiconque mais
d'autres cas qui arrivent sur le
territoire martiniquais peuvent cultiver
peuvent nous nourrir la population vous
pensez aux haïtiens voulais pas le dire
mais oui ça doit pour ne pas dire
haïtiens parce que dès qu'on prononce le
mot on est tous suspectés on est pointé
du doigt c'est la réalité c'est notre
réalité on le sait que bon il est vrai
que nous avons aussi les ceux qui
viennent de ces lots mais nous avons
aussi les laisser plus il est bas les
échos mondiale et dominique aime mais
dans l'actualité même à haut niveau 2 de
ce qui arrive quand destine mans on nous
montre que c'est parce que c'est
l'original ici
c'est qu'on nous compatriotes haïtiens
urbain il faut en parler ne sais pas
parce que nous sommes dans une élection
ne pas dire ce qui se passe sur le
territoire vous trouvez qu'il ya trop
d'étrangers au martinez je ne dis pas
qui a trop mais je dis que papa au fait
qu'on nous dit on nous dit qu'il ya 3500
jeunes qui s'en vont moi j'ai moins un
mot dernier fois le seul qui vient en
france mais hexagonal
mon frère me dit oh non c'est pas vrai
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de familles
martiniquaises papa maman enfants qui
viennent vivre là bas y a pas que les
jeunes donc vous voyez bien que les
martiniquais s'en vont et si les
matinées ses raisonnements la nature des
deux
de la chaise vide la ville du moins et
bombay il ya de la place toutefois
prévenu prenne la place quelle que soit
l'aide à l'immigration massive au niveau
des hexagonaux au niveau de deux des
chinois des arabes les juifs il faut
parler de tout ça à tous ces gens là se
voient petit territoire s'ils sont là
donc
d'être raciste de dire ça concernant la
situation et les problèmes rencontrés
dans votre circonscription en tout cas
celle dans laquelle vous vous présenter
la troisième celle de fort de france
quels seront vos deux ou trois priorités
est belle ne serait ce que pour
fort-de-france avec notre sol c'est
serge letchimy je crois que je vais
mettre l'accent beaucoup sur tout ce qui
et je dirai comment expliquer ça pour ne
pas dire de gros mots mais de tout ce
qui est magouilles de tout ce qui est là
où on dit que bon ben ça monsieur
l'alchimie s'est octroyé 70000 euros de
départ à la retraite
anticipé bon monsieur
ajar
lui ils sont trois et dix mille euros de
salaire dans une organismes de transport
que l'argent avait créé le groupe dow
qui n'engagent que oui oui j'ai entendu
que tout le monde l'a dit c'est sous les
réseaux je n'invente rien donc je dis
que lâchés sur le réseau n'est pas
forcément vrai oui mais bon je pense
qu'il ya des preuves et pour le moment
personne n'a porté plainte en
diffamation bon ce que je vais dire sous
fort de france je vais pas répéter tout
ce que les autres candidats disent que
oui la ville capitale elle laisse à
désirer au niveau de l'hygiène où l'on
sait pas ce qu'on va aller défendre à
l'assemblée nationale mais n'empêche que
il faut qu'on semblait nationale il faut
conclure wallace qu'avez vous à dire
d'essentiel pour convaincre les
électrices et les électeurs faut y aller
en quelques mots marine voilà donc ce
que je vais dire aux électeurs on nous
demande de renouveler la classe
politique on veut voir de nouvelles
têtes on a pas de débat télévisé donc
les dés sont pipés on le sait déjà il
faut tout pour que au deuxième tour vous
avez quand même le mime et le ppm ils se
tiennent par la barbichette tu manges
moi je mange je mange le gâteau je
laisse les miettes pour la population et
on ne veut plus de ça il faut
sanctionner ces gens est terminé merci
marie jeanne son ville